[Music]
all right let's go to jennifer in
phoenix hey jennifer what's going on
hi i'm good how are you i'm fantastic
man it must be the i'm just kidding how
are you
i'm pretty good good it's just a regular
time wherever you are so that's great
just a regular old time james and kelly
were making fun of me earlier about how
to read a clock and i'm not very good at
it so now i'm just uh i'm trying to
defend i'm trying to make jokes out of
my discomfort that's what i'm doing so
sorry jennifer you're walking into like
a room and everyone's laughing and
you're like oh what's going on so sorry
i just did that to you so what's up
well um
yeah i read to you it's pretty earlier
but thank you for taking my question of
course
i've been divorced uh from my ex-husband
for 10 years now
um and i have two little boys and it's
um
it's just been a struggle because
there's it's two different households
with different ideas of
how to do things and now that they're
starting to
get older and ask questions and notice
things they are
being faced with some difficult
subject matter and also just
trying to decide
who is telling the truth and
just things that you know a 10 year old
and a 12 year old shouldn't have to to
deal with and
you know as a parent i
thought
you know after years that
i would be past all this stuff i guess
oh you're just starting jennifer you're
just starting i'm so sorry oh man
oh i just i don't
i don't want things to be difficult for
them but i'm noticing patterns it's like
i've kept things very business-like
between
the relationship between their dad and i
just to avoid conflict
um
but now that they're starting to get
older they're starting to get caught in
the middle of all that yeah
so your boys are worth conflict if
they're not safe and your boys are worth
the conflict that's what parents are for
is to go between them and
pain right that's what parents do
so something must have happened recently
or a couple of things happen what have
you experienced recently that's
precipitating this call
well it's just it's
little things over the years that are
constant so
i'm hearing from them about
fighting going on at their dad's house
and you know i try not to get involved
in all that stuff because i don't know
what the situation is over there
and i don't want to talk bad about
their dad
because i want them to have a
relationship with their dad but it's
comments that i know that are hurtful
with them
um i like saying all the the only reason
that i married your mom was to have kids
like why would you say that
um and and just little things over the
years
making
negative comments about me
things that make them question their
themselves and their intelligence
you know they're just
being called you know awful names and
give me an example i don't
like my my older son he was diagnosed as
a
young child with adhd
and i really believe that's just a
result of all the turmoil from this
situation
but he's been called stupid and been
told his brain doesn't work
um
and i just i don't think that's helpful
no you can't do that with your kids
you absolutely can't deal with their
kids yeah
so you know you mentioned a second ago
that there's fighting going on there
what do you mean by that
um
yelling people getting pushed around
what do you mean by that
nasty yelling and screaming um i don't
think it turned to physical things but
um i know he's you know broken things in
the house
with him there
within there and i know that
for me
i know that that's not okay
but
legally that's not enough we're just sad
how do you know have you gone and asked
yes i have and some and an attorney told
you no that your their dad can call them
stupid until their brain's broken and
smash stuff and scream at them and
that's okay well the problem is is that
it's hard for me to prove that and when
i talk to the boys
they don't
they don't
want to tell me the whole story a lot of
times so i'll notice that they're upset
and i'll ask
but they're very reflecting because they
don't want to get their dad in trouble
and i've always told them like hey you
know i'm never gonna
judge you or whatever we can talk about
anything so we have a very you know
established open communication and they
know that
i'm just here to support them you know
and whether it's school or activities or
even stuff with their dad
so let's let's back out for for 30 000
feet okay
yeah let's say you guys were at a park
and
a mom showed up with her kid and they
were playing
and your son was climbing up this the
ladder to go down a slide
and she ran up to him and got in his
face
and started saying what are you stupid
what are you an idiot you're stupid
brain broken there was another kid in
line and he said i'm sorry ma'am i'm
sorry and he started climbing down and
she's like just stay there you stupid
idiot what would you do
well i would
we would leave obviously i wouldn't
allow him to to
receive that kind of but i would you
know have some things to say to that
person
so here's the thing your boys are
learning have learned to protect their
dad from you
because you've been protecting him for a
decade since your divorce
you know they're not safe over there you
know what they're living in is
wild
and you've even said things to me like i
don't want to get involved
i don't want i want them to be able to
be around their dad that's important
and so in doing so you've created a
fantasy that you're trying to uphold
you're trying to keep duct tape together
and the boys are on the other end of
this
and they've watched well it must be okay
um i must need to go over here
and this must just be part of fill in
the blank
and so as their mom
in a situation that you would not allow
with a stranger
they desperately need you to get
involved
desperately
and if that means taking them to a play
therapist who can talk with them get
them to tell them her or him things that
they wouldn't tell you great
if that's a school counselor great
if that's you calling him saying if you
call my kids stupid again we'll go to
court and i may lose but i'm then we're
going to go again and then we're going
to go again
because i'm not going to let people call
my kids stupid tell me of a broken brain
i'm not gonna let somebody smash stuff
and make my ten-year-old feel so
terrified in the home of someone who's
supposed to love them and keep them safe
i'm not
i guess i'm just concerned that if i
start pushing on this again which has
been my experience in the past that it's
just going to make it worse
which is something that you know as
their mom i am
worried about what do you mean you're
going to make it worse
it would just make it more
stressful for them over there that they
would get in trouble
um
do you hear what you're saying
yes thank you
yeah
they need you
now more than ever
and
if they get in more trouble
i mean i hear what you're saying and i
that fear is real i don't want to
minimize your fear but what i'm trying
to tell you is you're their mom
and if
by calling him and saying are you do not
call our son stupid he's not
i know there's a business arrangement
all that it's got to become a a
relational arrangement y'all are in this
forever together
right right
is he able to have a conversation with
you about this
like if you called him and said hey man
they're telling me that you tell him
that they're stupid
will he take it out on them
yeah what does that mean will he yell at
him further will he say what could be if
you told your mom on me and all that
kind of nonsense
yeah all of that
i think you got to sit down with an
attorney asap
because your boys aren't safe
and the attorney may tell you i'm so
sorry i can't do anything about this i
just don't think that's right
i do think your boys could go get an
eval
and
it's my guess is there's other stuff
going on there
do you would you believe that too
i would suspect yeah okay
go with your gut
because right now what your boys are
learning is some people are just mean
and crazy and we just put up with it
and if nothing else if nothing else
at least two years five years seven
years from now
there will be a track record that you
can show your boys and say i went to war
for you guys i lost every time but i
never gave up fighting for y'all
and it is okay
i tell people 24 7 365 don't talk bad
about your ex i believe that
wholeheartedly
but if one of your boys gets told
they're stupid you hold their face and
you look them in the eye and say that is
not right
and i know that your daddy loves you but
you are not stupid he should not have
said that
he is
wrong they've got to have somebody in
their life speaking truth into them a
different way and there's got to be a
physical aspect to that it will help a
young child it'll help them absorb it
okay
your kids at 10 and 12 are going to get
enough mixed messages at school
on the internet they're going to get it
everywhere they've got to have some
stability and they cannot have parents
who are smashing stuff throwing temper
tantrums screaming at them threatening
them
you can't do that
they are learning right now that this is
how you treat your children
and so the longer it goes before there's
some intervention from an adult who
cares about them the longer it gets
embedded in them that this is how dads
treat their kids
and this is how generational trauma goes
on and on and on
and i hate hate hate that you're the one
stuck in the middle of this i really do
and you're their mom
you're there mom
so today
today i'm on the phone with the lawyer
today i'm on the phone with school
counselor
today i'm on the phone with a play
therapist in the area that your school
counselor can recommend you
go talk to
your boys will talk
they'll tell somebody even if it's not
you
and get them with the right professional
care and then you find out your options
okay and if you find out if you i want
to be i want to be as
realistic as possible if you find out
hey i'm so sorry there's nothing here
dads are allowed to scream and smash
stuff in front of their kids they're
allowed to call their son stupid they're
allowed to tell their son's
biological lies that their brains are
broken or whatever
you've got to be hyper hyper intentional
about making sure those boys know when
they come to your house they're safe
that they are not stupid their brains
are not broken daddy is not telling you
the truth and it's okay to combat lies
it really is it's a difference between
saying your dad's a liar
it's different say your daddy is wrong
he is wrong and i'm sorry
and they you you're playing a long long
game now you're playing a 5 10 15 20
year game where you're gonna try to
rescue your boys from an abusive dad
and my gut tells me the older they get
the bigger they get the more um they
grow into
um a male a man body
that aggression's gonna get more and
more and more
and that means the earlier you can
squash this the better
the earlier earlier earlier go to bat
for them man they need you
they need you need you jennifer
ugh hate that
guys
husbands we need you man we need you
more than ever
gotta have your husbands
dad's gotta have you